Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new doctor strange 2 marvel video we have a new
report about the main villain of the movie it's a
little bit different from what we've heard before
but i'll explain what's going on with that and how
this all connects so if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
a bunch of big stuff coming up i'm doing loki
episodes in a couple weeks we're doing a marvel
disney plus giveaway for memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your predictions for doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness on the video it is probably going to be
the craziest marvel movie in the best possible way
we also have some news about what's going on with
spider-man 3 no way home and the new trailer that
they're probably going to be releasing real soon
i'll mention that at the end of the video too
because there is a connection between the events
of spiderman no way home and doctor strange 2.
but if you didn't see the news that was going
around the internet this past week according
to the illuminer and a couple of the other big
websites that were reporting this the new main
villain that they're using for doctor strange 2
is actually schumachorth it's not nightmare as
we previously believed previously we had heard the
director from the first doctor strange movie scott
derrickson talking about how he wanted to use
nightmare but then he left the movie sam raimi
mr spider-man himself came on to direct and they
did a big rewrite so no big surprise that they
would change the villain but they also did report
how he enters the story and what he's actually
doing during the movie what the stakes are and
how he's connected to the other characters he's
one of marvel's biggest villains metaphorically
and literally so we're slowly getting to higher
level cosmic concepts like the celestials in
eternity schumachorth for instance isn't a
cosmic concept but he is so ancient and powerful
that he predates the celestials and the birth
of this version of the mcu universe he was
born before the infinity stones were created
as with a lot of the bigger doctor strange
villains he is an extradimensional being of
immense power and he belongs to this group of
creatures that they refer to as the many angled
ones they're like the elder gods who ruled
over earth about twenty thousand years ago
he was originally defeated by a sorcerer from the
future from like the 30th century called seisnic
i know we're getting into time travel with the
loki series so that'll be really interesting
to see in the mcu but this sorcerer also went by
the name cagliostro who you may remember from the
first doctor strange movie because the ancient one
in doctor strange discussed the book of cagliostro
which was his grimoire with all of his most
powerful spells he went around trying to
accumulate the sum total of all magical knowledge
and put it in this book this will be important in
a second because we just saw wanda reading from
the darkhold another different but very powerful
grimoire of magic the next time that you see
shuma gorath in the comics he's actually being
defeated by a god called chrome from the conan
comics conan was a marvel character for a while
using something called the ironbound books of
schumachorth he imprisons him in these books
and the only way to release him is if someone uses
the books tries to use the magic that's in them
it's the exact same concept with cathone in
the darkhold cathode is the one who created the
darkhold he's the god of chaos he's always trying
to use the darkhold as a means to break into the
main mcu dimension getting people to read from
it since we're talking about sam raimi he did the
evil dead series army of darkness it's a little
bit like reading from the book of the damned clans
never a good idea to read from magical books if
you don't know what's going on schumacher is a
very lovecraftian style villain like one of the
eldritch horrors if you're not familiar with hp
lovecraft eldritch just means otherworldly but
when the term is used in science fiction fantasy
stories is usually just referring to some
ancient dark god from outside our dimension
this will start to sound familiar so schumacherth
rules over his own chaos dimension which exists
in the space between what you think of as the
normal universes of the multiverse like if you
think of each universe as being an infinite series
of sphere-like shapes next to each other the chaos
dimension where schumaguerth and the many angled
ones were born where they rule over is basically
the dark nothingness between all those universes
for example dormammu rules over the dark dimension
and his goal is to go around absorbing other
normal dimensions into his own making it larger
but the dark dimension is still part of what you
would consider the normal subset of universes
of the multiverse shuma gorath is sort of like
dormammu's boss if we're talking about tearless
here he's referred to as the lord of chaos master
of the old ones and ruler of a thousand dimensions
even though that sounds like a lot there are
infinite universes infinite dimensions of the
multiverse but he's not the god of chaos like
i said that's cathone but the old ones are also
another name for the elder gods cathone was one of
the most powerful elder gods and as i said he is
the one in the comics at least who wrote the book
that you see wanda reading from in Wandavision
but shuma gorath chaos lord is more powerful than
cathone so this should all start to sound familiar
the mcu just got done canonizing how scarlet
witch's chaos magic works in the darkhold
prophecy about her bringing about the end of
the world scarlet witch is also one of the main
characters of doctor strange 2 so in the way that
marvel simplifies things and does sort of cliff's
notes versions of really complicated comic book
backstories it sounds like they might be combining
a lot of elements of different characters in the
comics for their version of the doctor strange 2
villain a really good example of this is what they
did with dormammu during the first doctor strange
movie they sort of combined his backstory with
doctor strange with schumachora's backstory in
the comics the first big fight that dr strange
had with the schumacherth was actually when it
tried to take over the mind of the ancient one
and use him because it was a man in the comics
as a doorway back to earth doctor strange
was forced to kill him in order to stop it
from happening so you can see the similarities in
the plot of the first doctor strange movie where
the ancient one is slowly corrupted by the use
of dark magic dormammu's energy threatening to
allow him to enter and take over the main mcu
dimension until eventually she winds up dying
this also sounds familiar too the next time shuma
gorath tries to enter the main dimension was after
doctor strange's magical barriers and protections
were destroyed similar to what's happened between
avengers infinity war and avengers end game
with the loss of the infinity stones like the
time stone that wasn't the only thing that doctor
strange was using to keep earth safe from beings
like dormammu other extra dimensional beings but
it was his trump card it was the one thing that
they were afraid of so those other villains like
shuma gorath are powerful enough to sense when the
infinity stones were atomized by thanos they still
exist in the mcu because without them the flow
of time would be completely corrupted they'll be
getting into that concept during the loki series
but because they were atomized nobody else can
use them villains or heroes the only way to use
the infinity stones again would be to time travel
again and steal them from some earlier point in
the timeline but here's where we get into the plot
of wandavision in that Wandavision post-credit
scene and her reading from the darkhold so one
of sue mcgorth's biggest twists is trying to
take over the minds of other people and use the
ironbound books of schumachorth or like cathone
with the darkhold use people that read the book to
take over their minds and allow them to use their
powers to enter the main mcu dimension so in that
post-credits scene you see scarlet witch reading
from the darkhold seemingly in a trance like she's
astral projecting and reading from the book in the
astral plane there's a bit of an implied time jump
so it seems like she's been doing this for a while
and the idea is that slowly as she reads more and
more of the darkhold if they really are combining
some of these marvel villains eventually he'll be
able to take control of her mind in her body and
use her chaos magic powers to bring him to earth
which gets back to that whole prophecy that agatha
harkness was talking about the prophecy that
the scarlet witch would bring about the end of
the world i did a video about the deleted doctor
strange scenes that they were supposed to have
in Wandavision but then changed their minds about
at the last minute he was going to show up by the
finale and teach her about her magic even though
it's a bummer we didn't see him cameo on the
series they can just turn that into some of the
drama at the beginning of doctor strange 2 where
wanda is still pretty naive about how her powers
work like agatha hartness warns her you're going
to need me for what's coming and wanda just kind
of brushes it off like it's no big deal like i'm
not worried about that she begins to read from
the dark hold slowly her mind becomes corrupted
and shu mcgorth starts to take advantage of her
then they explain that's why things really start
to go off the rails there is a connection between
agatha hardness and shuma gorath in the comics he
actually fought a version of nicolas scratch who
is her son we don't know if this version of akita
the hardness from Wandavision had any children
she's hundreds of years old on the series so
i think they're just leaving the rest of her
story in the mcu to whichever marvel director
wants to bring her character back again but i
do 100 percent think that she will come back in
some future marvel project i do not believe that
she's supposed to be in doctor strange 2 though
but according to this report from illuminard
schumachur's story in doctor strange 2 begins with
him pursuing america chavez who's being played
by Xochitl gomez according to kevin feige here
because he wants to use her power to control the
entire multiverse so if you haven't read a lot
about her character america chavez is a person
who can open portals to any dimension that she
wants to she can also travel at near the speed
of light she was born in this special dimension
outside the normal dimensional space in the
presence of what they call the demiurge who is
the force that created the elder gods like cathone
so america chavez is connected to schumacherth but
after schumachorth the only cosmic villain that's
bigger than him if we're talking about escalation
with sequels if they do doctor strange three and
they like doing trilogies so i assume that at some
point they'll try to do a third doctor strange
movie they're doing four thor movies in four
captain america movies but the only character
who's actually bigger than him and more evil
is the one below all who's sort of the antithesis
of the one above all marvel's version of the one
true god of everything like there are lesser gods
with a little g like thor odin hella then you have
the actual god who i'm actually never expecting
to see in the live-action movies i don't think
they're ever going to try doing that character
it would just completely break every story that
they have how do you have stakes when you have
a character that's that powerful there was a
story that marvel did recently about a war between
the different demonic entities during the doctor
strange damnation series where mephisto actually
emerged victorious i know it all goes back to
mephisto everyone pull out your mephisto theories
it was sort of a version of avengers infinity war
in avengers end game but just for the magical
demonic cosmic entities and it also involves
schumacher it could be a concept that they try
to get into with their final doctor strange movie
whatever that winds up being in some future year
even though i do think the next real big concept
that marvel's building up to their next big event
will be galactus but hopefully that explains who
schumachorth is and how he sort of fits into the
grand marvel cosmic hierarchy and where he sort
of fits in terms of villains that they've done
so far obviously much more powerful than thanos
but i know i mentioned that doctor strange 2
is connected to spider-man 3 doctor strange is
going to be a big character during spider-man 3
no way home and it sounds like sony is actually
getting ready to release that first trailer
that might happen in the next couple of weeks
if it does of course i'll do a video whenever
they do release it my marvel loki episodes will
start posting in a couple weeks so make sure you
have alerts enabled so you don't miss any of that
i will name a new giveaway winner when i post my
next marvel video everyone click here for my brand
new marvel eternals trailer breakdown and easter
eggs and click here for my venom 2 trailer let
there be carnage thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!